this is gonna this one this is a a
segment for all of our socialist friends
out there we have the story from
barons.com I love the name Russia's
Swift exclusion could spur cyber attacks
10 stocks that could benefit that's an
amazing headline if I've ever seen it so
let me break that down what were you
saying about uh moral Decay moral Decay
yeah so yeah exactly Swift is the
international payment system it's like
the society for worldwide what is it you
know International or something or
whatever Financial transactions yeah
there you go I don't know something like
that and uh it's the banking system so
they're slowly kicking out Russia's
Banks from Swift which I believe could
result in Russia being Unleashed they're
already sanctioned they're already in
this position and now you're saying
we're going to remove any leverage we
have over you outright just get rid of
backing them into a corner or unleashing
them letting them letting them off the
hook letting or letting them off the
Leafs what's the quote a man with
Nothing Left to Lose is a dangerous man
yes and so uh I believe you know I said
this before that I think Banning Russia
from Swift would be a huge mistake
because you're effectively escalating
the conflict the most extreme way
possible Russia has now got no ties to
these other countries or financial
institutions so if they nuke you it
won't affect them because you're now
severed you severed all those economic
ties well Barons excellent Name by the
way is saying you can benefit by well
they're not saying you could they're
saying 10 stocks that could benefit and
they go on to list a bunch of companies
like hey you know you know what they're
saying they're basically telling people
without telling them directly buy these
stocks war is good for profits always a
way to make money in the markets I
suppose and here I am trying to figure
out what stocks they're telling me to
buy volunteer of course palantir yeah
they say Palo Alto networks z-scaler
crowdstrike tenable Holdings varana
systems Fortinet Telos mandiant palantir
and cyber Arc software so is it ethical
to make money off the decline
I don't I why wouldn't it I don't even
know what the word ethics means anymore
can you define that for me I mean
I mean but I guess so many of that so
much of that has become an individual
thing rather than something we would all
agree on nice yeah it is sociological
ethics and then there's personal ethics
this is a good question though is it is
it um
is it okay to profit off the decline of
the United States I I tweeted out that I
bought a bunch of uh Russian vodka the
other day before they banned it people
were like this is really unethical of
you to go get embargoed products like
you want to make money off and I'm like
oh you know it's not I can't do anything
to stop it I think as a society it's
unethical not to profit off of the
decline of nature like the the
destruction creation of nature if we're
not trying to profit off of it then
we're not doing our system Justice
well what do you mean by the destruction
of Nature and I guess also Define profit
what if the profiting off it makes it
worse like acceleration well yeah
definitely that's bad yeah I guess I
guess you know hold on a lot of people
are probably going to say not true rip
off the Band-Aid or peel it slowly yeah
yeah you know uh rip it off or rip it
with the hair not against the hair have
you seen that Meme where it's like in
the event of a nuclear strike lay down
face towards the blast and put your
hands on your head that way the blast
hits your head sooner and you'll die
faster oh my goodness it's like a dark
meat was it unethical for them to tell
kids to Duck and Cover in the Cold War
get under your desk and then the nuclear
blast you'll you might have some chance
to survive which they were though and
they knew they wouldn't oh yeah
depending on the distance
yeah the initial blast radius for a lot
of nuclear bombs is not it's not as
white people think they think it's like
30 miles it's like a half mile maybe
which is massive there's a there's this
thing I think the New York Times Did
where they showed an overlay of
different nuclear bombs and how it would
affect Manhattan and it's like Yeah from
River to River Manhattan is hit so if
you're in during if you're in Jersey
City and Manning gets hit by a nuke
you're not in the immediate blast or
radiation Zone but you're gonna hit by
the shock wave so you see the light you
duck in cover because glass and oh yeah
shards are going to go forward do you
guys have a bomb shelter no she's ready
no uh but you know let's get the shovel
none of you have bombed on on Zillow
they were selling a uh Warhead like
missile underground oh yeah did you see
that that was wild well yeah but you
could it was like 300K yeah get a
missile silo you could and they're
they're really deep and it's not even
that expensive like like you got to
think about buying a house these days
the prices are going up 300K was it like
16 floors that's that's cheaper than a
townhouse go live in Minnesota I think
was it was it Jake Paul or like Mr Beast
they went to one of these emergency
shelter nuclear silos that'd be fun and
it's like you live underground for 30
years in the event of a nuclear strike
or something but does it come with the
missile is the real question I think
they took the missile
they took it how can you still
well I can tell you this
um I don't think it's wrong to profit
necessarily it depends on how you look
at it but I'll say since all of this
stuff has been happening and getting
crazier I've I've certainly bought stuff
that I think is going to help me I've
bought you know we've got bug out kits
we've gotten emergency food that's just
like I would like to survive if bad
stuff happens but I've bought silver and
gold yeah I've bought Bitcoin and
Bitcoin just went up quite a bit so as
soon as they were talking about banning
Russia from Swift I was like I better
buy more Bitcoin when I learned about it
well so so real quick because if Russia
is kicked off of Swift they're going to
have to replace their International
transactions with some kind of
infrastructure and Bitcoin is is
essentially free infrastructure they
still have to build some
russian-specific you know hubs and stuff
so then I thought why would they use
anything but Bitcoin if they've already
got a bunch if it already exists and
it's already connected internationally
you're effectively telling them to go on
this decentralized Shadow network
instead of the government controller one
they're gonna be like fine I thought
bitcoin's gonna Skyrocket because of
this but more importantly I don't want
to be holding US Dollars yeah let me
just tell you man that beer you got
there old 690 it's a great place gone
prices oh yeah for sure they're a local
Brewery and their prices went up yeah
and I noticed like I I maybe we bought
more I don't know but it was more
expensive than a couple months ago when
we bought it and it's probably inflation
yeah we we went to go buy some whiskey
from the liquor store we get the good
stuff the price doubled that's the
trifecta we've got the pandemic we've
got the Russia phobia of the Cold War
but now we got to get the uh the
economic crap the 80s uh 80s gas
shortage and hyperinflation we got to
get the hyperinflation the wheelbarrows
cash when I was it was 2006 seven eight
when I first learned about the military
economic order basically I was like well
I can't profit off this in good
conscience so I stopped making money
completely I was totally poor for like a
decade lived in abject almost not abject
poverty but pretty close to like living
in my car kind of poverty because I just
did not want to profit off the system
but it was to the point where I was
destroying myself like I couldn't
participate and help the system and I
realized lies if you want to untangle a
ball of yarn first you need to get a
hold of the ball of yarn I need to be
rich to fix this system from the inside
so I am profiting off this unethical
treatment I don't know if slaves in
uyghur China and things like that rich
is probably the wrong word you need you
need to command influence yeah that's
true because the BET one of the greatest
things money gets you is influence and
that's what a lot of these rich people
want to do is buy a YouTube let's
actually make their words for them and
that's that's actually that's actually I
think a contradictory statement and
money doesn't buy you influence you can
try to buy influence exactly Michael
Bloomberg that guy dumped a lot of money
into this show a diminishing return on
his investment no it's because his ideas
are garbage you know so he can he dumped
what half a half a billion dollars so
people were saying it was really funny
they were like Tim you did a video
ragging on Michael Bloomberg and a
Bloomberg and I was like I would like to
thank Michael Bloomberg for sponsoring a
video where I rag on him for 20 minutes
we did a cartoon about this when the
Bloomberg advertisements were everywhere
just ripping on the Bloomberg
advertisements if y'all want to check
that out and they were people were
commenting like oh I got a Bloomberg
advertisement before this of course
because he's trying to counter that
messaging from you but it doesn't work
doesn't work no it makes my video
funnier yeah yeah so look there was a
there's a really funny story I read ones
from BuzzFeed maybe I shouldn't say it's
funny but there's this YouTuber who had
300K subscribers and was working as a
waitress and she said one day a little
girl was like oh my God you're so and so
why are you working as a waitress and
she was like oh I just you know it's a
job and then she went in the back and
cried because like she's famous but
broke and it's like yes you can have a
lot of influence and no money influence
is more valuable in a lot of ways and
depending on the type of influence
you're trying to do if you're trying to
threaten systems that do have more money
than you there is a cut off point for
how influential you're going to be
because if you don't have any money to
fight back what these people are going
to do to you they will steamroll you the
rich can absolutely squash the poor and
anything they'll you can get this is why
the Press focus on YouTubers when they
slander people you know you'll have
someone
um oh who's the guy from Braveheart I
can't remember Mel Gibson thank you uh
this beer hit hard yeah
um you literally call Jews oven Dodgers
and you'll get plenty of Articles from
mainstream media that are like Mel
Gibson on a fancy vacation at this show
at that show but a YouTuber will say one
off-color word like they'll say [ __ ]
once or something and that'll get a
whole article in all these different
Outlets they'll only be referred to as
extremist right wing this that because
they know they can get away with it
because Mel Gibson can afford massive
amounts of lawyers yeah representative
whereas YouTubers don't really have that
I think I think we've got um with Kyle
rittenhouse's you know he's going to do
yeah but he's got he's going to be
bankrolled no no for sure for sure but
I'm saying him and project Veritas I
think are gonna help change that game
but they're still they've they've hit
that threshold of the amount of money
you have to have to be able to fight
back again yeah but the elites because
if you if you if you are just small if
you're someone I mean Tommy Robinson had
money but you can just send someone to
jail
yeah you can't afford a lawyer yeah if
they know you're threatening the idea is
to change the system without them
realizing that it's like uber appeared
and it was a threat to the taxi system
but they didn't realize it till Uber was
prevalent thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there